eh bien ce soir on partage je
partage un peu de ma culture en faisant un
ragoût de cerf orignal et aussi avec du sauvage
écrire un plat sur la cuisse pour les
végétariens et aussi faire un
riz frit Bannock traditionnel et du spectacle du lac
Ontario je suis un  bon chemin et vous savez quand
j'étais jeune j'ai été adopté donc j'ai perdu ma
culture pendant une grande partie de ma vie quand j'ai
eu 18 ans je suis retourné montrer le lac et j'ai
commencé à apprendre ma culture et
c'est l'un des moyens l'un des  les
méthodes traditionnelles que j'ai commencé à apprendre,
mon oncle m'emmenant chasser combien de
viande utilisez-vous ce soir pour cette oh
bonne question,
je crois que c'est quatre livres d'orignal,
puis deux livres ici et puis j'ai une
colonne vertébrale de l'équipement
pas vraiment obtenir  la saveur donc c'est comme un
mirepoix comme le céleri carotte et les
oignons dedans sel et poivre au goût
et ensuite je vais juste le laisser bouillir
aussi je vais avoir du riz
plus tard et puis aussi des pommes de terre et puis
je suis  va faire une sorte de comme un roux
et le ramasser  merci
merveilleux alors comment appelleriez-vous cette
recette a-t-elle un nom spécifique une
mousse profonde oui spécial maison vous
savez parce que euh nous avons tous des
recettes différentes et ce n'est pas c'est ma façon traditionnelle d'
accord ouais ouais alors je laisse
mijoter et  alors je vais commencer à sauter l'
huile est sur le dessus ouais et puis je la goûterai
si elle en a besoin de plus un peu comme oh
j'essaie de ne pas mettre trop d'épices dedans
tu sais traditionnellement ce n'était pas comme
ça
il y a tout  des saveurs naturelles des
pommes de terre, je ne pense pas que nous ayons vraiment eu
cela jusqu'à ce que les Européens arrivent,
essentiellement une
course contre les champignons, les
baies, les canneberges, nous sommes une grande partie des
framboises mélangées avec nos gars,
alors que le riz pousse dans le nord de l'
Ontario  à ma connaissance, je sais qu'à une
époque appelée shoaling wild race, il y avait
une entreprise comme celle-là, donc la
viande de l'animal que vous tuez et la viande que
vous en gagnez vous allez tout donner
crier un oui
arbre arbre pas de joie  tu vas garder mais
nous avons plus  e plus qu'assez surtout
pour ceux qui peuvent se produire ouais
donc ce qui a été béni de pouvoir
ramener à la maison un nadir à notre famille